Eddie it is right smack bang in the
middle of the e3 press conferences for
2019 probably one of the biggest things
that's come out so far is xbox scarlet
this next-generation console that Xbox
is talking about we got a Talking Heads
trailer from the Microsoft oppressor the
other day but what exactly is project
scarlet aside from the buzz tubes yeah
so some of those buzz terms were like 8k
four times as powerful as the Xbox one X
has a solid state drive 120 frames per
second faster loading time so those are
some of the things they talked about but
you know overall project scarlet is
Microsoft's plan for their
next-generation consoles so there's
multiple reports happening right now
that are saying that scarlet is the
overall plan for this next generation
strategy comprising a very high spec a
very powerful console codenamed anaconda
as well as a lower spec console aimed at
kind of you know the masses at a lower
price point codenamed of Lockhart so
kind of like what the Xbox one
generation was that comprised of the s
the X and that family yeah that seems to
be the way to think about it going
forward you know another thing to talk
about about scarlet is they're more
powerful console will have a disk drive
and that's interesting because they're
you know Microsoft has toyed with the
idea of getting rid of one so but it's
people are probably happy to know that's
coming back not only for games but for
you know physical media of all types so
do we know so far
whether that diskless drive plan will
make an appearance in this scarlet
generation so there isn't anything
confirmed at this stage that seems to be
one of the pieces of speculation that
this lower this lower pricepoint lower
spec model could be the more you know
console that they're looking at more
towards the future when things are more
digital in streaming so you could see
that console not having a disk drive but
this is all speculation at this point
you know nothing is locked down all
right so what do we know for sure
so one thing for sure is you know
Microsoft is really stressed that they
want this new console Xbox scarlett to
be backwards compatible so the games you
have on Xbox one
even Xbox 360 and the original Xbox
they're talking about four generations
of you know Xbox games coming forward
with you two Xbox Scarlett they've said
look not every game
you know might not be possible to bring
every game due to licensing things like
that
various compatibility issues but that is
their plan right now and it'll also
carry forward with your Xbox one
accessories including controllers so
that is really good to hear because
previously you know when you move from
console generation to console generation
you kind of lose some of that
compatibility and have to you know rebuy
games rebuy accessories like controllers
this time it appears you won't have to
do that and that is you know a pretty
big selling point and that's pretty
similar to what Sony have said ahead of
the official release of PS 5 or whatever
they're gonna call that next-generation
console as in a similar vein that all of
your ps4 games your ps4 accessories will
also be able to carry forward yeah it's
really setting up to be one of those you
know Microsoft and Sony you know going
at it with their new other new consoles
and really that competition is good for
everyone and it's good to see both
companies kind of embrace that path
forward just makes it for a more
seamless you know an easier transition
when you move from console generation so
in terms of release type we know it's
holiday 2020 they haven't said anything
official on price yet no there's nothing
on price so for context the Xbox 1x in
the United States launched for 500 us so
that was you know the top of the top the
premium consoles so it remains to be
seen where that will land but presumably
Xbox 1x will have to come down in price
point as this new console comes out no
word yet though on exactly what that
will be a Lockhart again the lower spec
model will presumably come in
you know below that but at this point
Microsoft has said absolutely nothing
about price point yes we'll probably
expect to hear more about the price as
we get closer to that holiday 2020
launch winter but speaking of the launch
window we do already know about a launch
title is that right yes that's right
halo infinite the next entry Microsoft's
big series that's been dormant since
2015's halo 5 halo infinite will be a
launch title for the Xbox Scarlet
platform you know that game runs on a
brand-new engine so you would think it'd
be a could be a technical showcase for
what this new console is capable of
great well do let us know down in that
comment section what you guys think
about everything we know so far about
scarlet how you reckon it's shaping up
compared to what we know about the PS 5
and we will have plenty more ìiî goodies
for you so stay tuned to game spot
you
[Music]